Now we just looked at how to use the insert command
from the PyMongo client in order to get documents into our
MongoDB database. A better way to do this in my opinion,
is to output all of our documents as a Json file.
And that's what I did here. So, instead of
our Python cleaning program, actually putting data into MongoDB directly.
We simply separate the two concerns, the task of
cleaning the data from the task of getting it into
mongoDB. And the intermediary we use is a file
that has one Json document per line. Now we can
bulk import this data into mongoDB using the mongo import
system command. I'll show you a very common use for
mongo import here. See the instructor notes for
the link to the mongo import documentation. Okay, mongoimport
has a number of command-line parameters associated with
it, and we can see those by typing --help.
Okay, other way to get documentation on mongoimport.
Okay, so let's use mongoimport to get our auto's
data into a collection. First, I'm going to
specify the database, and we'll continue using the examples
database that we've been using all along. And then I'm going
to specify the collection into which this data should be stored. In
this case I'm going to store it in another collection, myautos2. And then
finally, I need to specify the file that I actually want to
import. That file is in the same directory, and it's called
autos.json. Now if I run this, we get an, a nice output
message telling us that we imported those same documents we saw before
when we were using the Insert command in order to get data
into MongoDB. So now we've looked at two different
ways to get data into MongoDB. And there are others.